Welcome back everyone to be my new stranger
thing season 4 trailer their having this big
Netflix TUDUM, kind of been it's their replacement
for comic con.
So that's why we're getting all this footage
and all these new trailers.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos I was he
this is all dropping next year.
They haven't given us the exact release date,
thereby gonna wait till early next year drop
another really big trailer to tell you exactly
which states going to be dropping just turning
the beginning the footage of working our way
through shot by shot.
There's a couple other clips that I haven't
cover before the also include in this to because
that in a couple teaser trailer for season
4.
So far, but the first teaser trailer starts
what they're calling the Creel house teaser.
Like in the previewer they were introducing
the clip they're saying where underperformers
that were used to film the Creel house stuff
but now just as living room South Korea house
from one location you can take that right
now morning you very very strange we hope
you enjoy and we'll see if you will and runs
back she starts with a huge flashback to it
seems that the 1950s like this old time he
flashback clip of a murder house called the
Creel house in this is probably the Creel
family for what is named they play it like
a typical family moves in all happily to this
new house, but in typical horror genre fashion.
It winds up being a murder house.
This seemingly haunted, but because were in
the stranger things universe a lot of what's
happening in the house when seems like is
haunted seems familiar to things that were
happening in the earlier seasons of the show.
Like is the old time music continues to play
they start noticing weird things around the
house and you kind of jump cuts forward in
time look a little girl sees the dead animal
in the yard sitting at dinner in the electrical
system starts going haywire starts flashing
the radio cuts in and out, then we jump forward.
It just seems like the guy, winds up going
crazy and killing the rest of his family.
They cut to present day with a version of
the team basically being Ghostbusters.
They even have the pin Ghostbusters if you
river at the beginning of season two.
They literally dressed up as the Ghostbusters
for Halloween that year and getting super
meadow with this one of the kids from stranger
things is in the Ghostbusters afterlife movie
the doing the stranger things were it's a
Ghostbusters team of little kids it's simple
part who plays Mike on stranger things I busy
playing a different character in the Ghostbusters
universe is is really weird meta thing going
on with her parenting the Ghostbusters referencing
Ghostbusters stuff that we actually have a
Ghostbusters movie with a bunch of little
kids in it.
The circle of Easter eggs are now complete.
But the thing you might notice year when the
lights are flashing and things are going crazy
in the house electrical systems are going
all haywire this as you seems very similar
to what was happening in Joyce and Will's
house.
When will was in the upside down trying to
contact his mother flipping all the lights
trying to communicate with her to let her
know that he was alive.
Just trapped in another dimension.
So, because this is the stranger things universe
and we know that everything has its own version
of itself in the upside down this version
of his house in the upside down the team seems
like it's investigating a way to get into
the upside down inside this murder house like
a summer where the barrier between the normal
world in the upside down as a little bit weaker.
Like say underneath the star court mall and
at the old Hawkins lab that they close the
portal to at the end of last year when the
big machine exploded you may also remember
way back a couple years ago when the early
early stranger thing season 4 teaser trailers.
There was a clock sounded people were like
is this big been it sounds like the big Ben
clock now because we see the grandfather clock
chiming in this teaser trailer in the Creel
house.
We know that that was what it was referencing
its this grandfather clock is all these questions
about how they were going to connect with
the hopper storyline in Russia we did actually
get some new hopper trailer footage in the
last big teaser trailer with him.
This flamethrower seemingly still inside that
Russian presently kind of seems like he still
in Russia is a really interesting thing about
the set design here.
Even though it's obviously meant to look really
creepy.
Like a murder house typically would in a horror
movie.
The design on that stainglass window on the
front door with the flower opening up kind
of remind you of the head of the demo Gorgon
opening up like a really dangerous kind of
flower it was also a short teaser they release
the other day to with them investigating a
bunch of news clippings playing it as if Dustin
in the group are investigating the murder
house before they go visit it
as you see it is hyping up the mystery of
what's actually going on with this house.
Like I said a lot of these things are happening
here seems familiar to what was happening
at will in Joyce's house during season one
when he was in the upside down trying to flip
all the switches and communicate with her
messing with the electronics but the other
really, really noticeable thing here at the
beginning of this clip when all the kids walk
in is that they are way older I was he in
previous seasons they had the two different
storylines where you have the high schoolers
then you have the young kids knows they get
older, there's all the jokes about how Steve
is kind of adopted most of the kids is like
super best friends with Dustin out and a lot
of the other kids just seem like they are
high schoolers at this point.
Even though they've all gotten the same amount
older Lucas, just seems like he is way older
than all the other kids even though their
supposed to be about the same age.
But you have Dustin Steve Max Robin who obviously
is there was Steve, because are now working
together the kind like a little sub- team
by themselves.
Nancy and Lucas so we don't know where 11
is in this clip we saw some other footage
of her with what seems like some government
stooges trying to hold her back is another
clip of them at a high school rally like school
has begun again at some point during the series.
As they all come back to town every mention
the new footage of hopper with the flamethrower
and then we have the new footage of this person
walking away from the car Rick this burning
in the middle of the street so just a mishmash
of a bunch of new scenes in obviously focusing
on this Creel house is a really important
location it what seems like the early part
of the season in the way their hyping up this
grandfather clock that is trying to make it
seem like it has some deep connection to the
upside down like, is that it just sounds like
this is going to be a place with a be a weakness
in the barrier between dimensions in the upside
down weaker than you would find some other
place, because at some point they have to
get to the upside down to fight the actual
mine flare and defeated in its home dimension.
I think that's the whole ideas that like they
could defeated as many times as they want
inside the normal world.
As it slowly has broken and over the couple
seasons.
Like of the in the last year that giant flesh
goo monster was really just as avatar so they
may defeated it.
But they didn't kill the actual mine flare
itself, which is sort of like a flesh puppet
being controlled by the mine flare from the
upside down.
We haven't really got in the last couple of
big trailers is how they actually reconnect
with hopper you tell all the jokes about David
harbour in the black widow movie like oh he
obviously went over to Russia became red Guardian
and that's where hopper's been this whole
time.
But the way the David harbour talks about
the hopper character.
He says that this is like the down and dirty
is the you've ever seen.
Hopper like that she a really really solid
season for hopper if you like the characters
had some ups and downs in the previous seasons.
Even though he's been a main character.
The whole time.
Like the closest you get to seeing full-blown
action hero hopper obviously he's got escape
that Russian prison to remember that early
stranger thing season 4 trailer with hopper
on chain gang in Siberia Russia you have this
character played by Jack in her car from game
of thrones most people know him as Jaquen
H'gar you may have seen in his mother series
recently.
He's a fairly prominent actor, but is in at
least a couple episodes during season for
the beginning of the season, he's only listed
on IMDb for episodes one and two, but his
name is Dimitri in the way his character description
reads is that he someone who befriends hopper
so it sounds like he winds up helping hopper
escape.
Also relevant is the title of episode one,
the reveal the title of season 4 episode one
is the hellfire club, so I'm assuming that
this little Ghostbusters group that they put
together this murder mystery group trying
to investigate things like the Scooby gang
these wind of calling the hellfire club like
this is a special new club that they formed
is a whole bunch more trailers that are gonna
becoming this big Netflix event.
I believe is gonna be a new Witcher season
two trailer later tonight, so I'll try to
do a video for that as soon as possible as
well make sure you enable alerts so you don't
miss any those videos and of course will do
more.
Stranger things videos in the drop more trailer
footage for that.
If you spotted any Easter eggs in this footage
that I didn't talk about in the video just
right them blown the comments everyone click
here to learn what's going on with the new
Spider-Man no way home marvel lawsuit click
here for my brand-new eternal trailer for
kit harington's black knight character.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see the next video!